[Music]
[Music]
we've passed on all we now the thousand
generations live in you now but this is
your fight
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we'll always be with you
[Music]
no one's ever really gone
[Laughter]
[Music]
Arthur does it he'll have someone to
talk to
[Music]
my mother always tells me to smile and
put on a happy face
she told me I had a purpose to bring
laughter and joy to the world
is it just be
or is it getting crazier out there
though your heart is aching smile even
though it's breaking when there are
cloud in the sky
you'll get by but if you see sorrows
maybe tomorrow
what's so funny freak
[Music]
Gotham's lost its way
what kind of coward would do something
that cold-blooded someone who hides
behind a mask
[Music]
I used to think that my life was a
tragedy
[Music]
realize
[Music]
it's a comedy
[Music]
you just
life's not fair
visit my little friend while some are
born to feast others spend their lives
in the dark
[Music]
begging for scraps
[Music]
everything you see
exist together in a delicate balance
[Music]
while others search for what they
contain a true king searches the what he
can give
[Music]
run away Simba
and never return
you must take your place
[Music]
and the circle of life
[Music]
everything you see in here is either
haunted cursed or has been used in some
kind of ritualistic practice nothing's a
toy it's safer for these things to be in
here than out there sometimes it's
better to keep the genie in the bottle
don't your parents keep any creepy stuff
around you keep it all locked away in a
room so that we're safe it's not really
good for anyone to go in there
why'd you do to get in there
why don't you tell
[Music]
I think you have the wrong house there's
no Annabelle here the don't it's a
beacon for other spirits
[Music]
[Music]
gotta go fast
20 minutes ago an energy surge knocked
out power across the entire Pacific
Northwest this needs someone who could
figure out exactly what we're dealing
with
you're not suggesting who I think you're
suggesting we have no choice
what are you in charge here yes I know
I'm wrong mommy charge allow me to
clarify in a sequentially ranked
hierarchy based on level of critical
importance the disparity between us is
too vast to quantify agent stone the
doctor thinks you're basic listen pal I
don't know if you realize I'm sorry I
major what was your name Ben Joe nobody
cares meow
basically it looks like I'm gonna have
to save your planet no but thank you for
asking
whatever this creature is our job is to
security neutralize it see what makes it
tick
[Music]
look at this
I took 9 million steps today
stay in there to be quiet how much
longer I can't breathe in here
do you have your child in that Bank no I
mean yes it's a child but it's not Maya
it's not your child
smells like bodies bring an old ham
sandwich ladies and gentlemen of NASA
this is Charles Xavier hope is on the
way you're doing space missions now cool
we get the astronauts we bring them home
go heat signatures rising fast we gotta
get out of here where's Jean where is
she
she should be dad did you hear what the
kids are calling you Phoenix
hello gene who are you the better
question is who are you
something's happening to me well had
this control bad things happen but it
feels good that power destroyed
everything that ever came into contact
with until you the TechSmith fear you
and what they fear we seek to destroy
Chocula
go die
she's still off that she's not Jean
anymore
are you threatening me that's right
Andy I know his move has been really
tough but this is supposed to be a new
start for us remember you said you were
gonna try to make you focus buddy can
connect to and control all of your
caslen products and smart home devices
introducing your new best friend
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow tell you something and I need you to
read me
I think Chucky did something
and if you know something you better
tell me somethings wrong with talking
buddy can connect you and control all of
Chucky is a toy this could be anywhere
welcome to dazzling cars
[Music]
we have to stop him
[Music]
goodbye daddy what we are witnessing
here is the return of tightness
[Music]
how many these things are there 17 and
captain that musta
[Music]
ma Rodin Ghidorah
they're moving like a pack they're
hunting they all respond directly to an
alpha
we stop this Ghidorah we stop them all
is there another creature that might
stand a chance against him
[Music]
our planet will perish so will we
[Applause]
less we set Godzilla free
oh yeah sure let's bring him in for a
beer no this time we join the fight
run
[Music]
this is guys in this world we just live
in it
damn right
we are a rumor
recognizable only as deja vu and
dismissed just as quickly
we are the best-kept secret in the
universe I know I want in you race my
parents memories but you didn't get mine
took me 20 years to find you how many
people can say that I found you
which makes be perfect for this job
[Music]
[Music]
you will be with Asian teens I might be
you Karelian scum and fYI your little
Club here sucks
come on well it's not gonna save itself
I'm driving that really should be here
Joey I thought that we were here we are
[Music]
wait are you a queen indeed she is I
pledged loyalty eternal to you you know
I'm not interested too late I already
pledged the loyalty I wish you'd said no
no no before we've never faced a threat
like the hive they can take the form of
anyone I haven't seen that before
even our own agents do we have a plan
sometimes you have to trust your gut
men and black has been compromised on
trust no one we protect the earth
that means everyone and everything on
yeah we love a man in black
the men and women in black yeah
perfectly good are you suggesting that
we try the most powerful weapon in the
galaxy for fun turn it up a few meets
Rex ever since he was a puppy he's been
the Queen's top dog he's always been
popular in the palace and he's shakin
paws with the best the brightest and the
craziest fantastic little place you got
here Liz life was pretty good until he
got locked out of the palace and put in
the doghouse owes a nice little puppy
room one don't get involved with strays
Rex you drool in perhaps we could get
formally acquainted real great never
cross Theisen newsy news out dog he's a
pussycat
Rule three trust no one
I want to go home I'm the Queen's corgis
[Music]
I can't get out of here on my own the
knighted we stand divided we fall
we need to work together our real battle
is if it's fear I'm too fluffy to die we
conquer it we set ourselves free hold it
tight
[Music]
your father died protecting this city he
taught you to follow your conscience in
an often cruel world what happened
we're staying 18 years 20 cops case why
would I hear they responded to a robbery
automatic weapons to shooters we have
training what were you when your
father's captain King is for you for a
reason
I will find them we just kill cops
either one you got to move fast
cosmatos plates are stolen we will catch
these guys in the next three or four
hours they vanished
are you gonna do this close the eye the
21 bridges in and out of Manhattan shut
them down Three Rivers closed four
tunnels block oh stop every train and
loop the subways then we flood the
island blow another dismay sense the
biggest 4:30 he's walked into 300
they'll have to open Manhattan by
morning eight dead policeman is one
thing for the stock market losing
billions of dollars is quite another
this whole thing is filthy you know I
mean you gotta be to move to be honey
killers of cocaine what's going on here
I just need the truth vessel
I told me you were feeling the guy kills
cop killers
see these dad in every couple dies
your fortune is mine
[Music]
least I know they're not gonna scape
decided and the only cop tonight who
speaks first and second
I will find out why did not happen
gotta represent it's quite the fairy
tale you got going on here from top
flight model in Moscow it's rubbing
shoulders with the elite blows the
nature of your relationship with all
like feeling calm you enter this hotel
at 1:37 p.m. did you notice anything
suspicious
like what
[Music]
can't you look at the hotel security
covers tapes were raised like retirement
pros
[Music]
[Music]
how did you do that your next target
isn't perished
they'll be no backup any questions which
way
[Music]
how do you want most of the world
[Music]
hi what's your name
[Music]
please be a 5-star ride I'm still how do
you do come to me Tommy PD let's go
what do you have a more specific address
having neighborhoods that's not how you
selected the uberpool roschmann or what
ladies official police business go see
your friend oh I am not touching that
the baby gun it allows you to fire it
for you
you know my dad you shouldn't go up
there you kidnapped me cuz I'm free
control exactly just my judge it's gonna
work ready we killed some people
[Music]
hello operator
we need help someone's trying to murder
us BB hey hey look maybe you wanted to
hang out
it's the last summer after high school
ends the last chance to decide who we
want to be and who we want to be with
think about you supposed to wear to a
breakup how about we agreed to stay
friends just friends okay
walk away
Oh for god sakes this is gonna be the
summer it's clean the slate hey you're
really good can't believe you're wasting
all this to study business right over a
safe stable career in the arts beach
bonfire party lay down sure yeah I'm not
actually gonna go out with him
no he's young he's successful and he's
hot gross so what's the deal a human
thieves we haven't talked about it yeah
keeping the mystery alive I'm diggin me
sometimes I fear whether I'm even
capable of love welcome to my office
you're making it very hard to judge you
someone's just going by way too fast I
wanted to see you before we both leave
for school hey I got it go but have an
export okay
Phoebe there's something I need to tell
you
you just went along and you did nothing
I didn't know what to do
I've never been through this before
[Music]
one last summer
the last chance to go all in
I mean what's there to lose right
[Music]
I don't want to give it away it was the
butler mother day leave my books alone
okay just let me timber what brings you
across the pond it's my honeymoon
where's your husband dad I'd must sleep
days dead asleep sir if you don't return
to your seat I'm gonna have to call the
cops
hey we've actually been married for 15
years but we just Charlie is inviting us
to spend the weekend with him on a young
Russian the pavilions Audrey did you
have a fool around on a boat I just lay
here and the boat goes all the work
should we pull it up now it's a foot
long my husband he's a detective how
could it better don't put it back
[Applause]
my name is Victor a little Honda Lacroix
I will now summon you for questioning oh
why is that smoke ring so could he do
that did you notice anything out of the
ordinary
what we didn't do this someone's trying
to frame us we do things together so can
we please just figure this out they died
[Music]
killed someone do you think that's
possible for trying those were warning
shots honey I do this we gotta look
confident
[Music]
I love your sweet look what you just
made me do what is going on in this
crazy place in this world nothing is
what it seems a few moments ago things
were different a lot different I was
with my brother Charlie
with my connections I could find your
brother no problemo one of them is the
world's greatest secret agent this one
over the last several months a number of
citizens vanished into thin air
do you think it's the same people who
took my brother I'm 100% almost sure
well well you weren't the strongest
fiercest warriors that can find now you
gotta fight for your life in my arena
[Applause]
here he comes here he comes here he
comes
Charlie's out there all alone
come on let's motivate
we're heading into dangerous territory
well played
there's no chance of dad's or anything
right
it's okay to be excited to see me you're
only human
[Music]
all right charlie
we can do that
[Music]
tell the boss tells here to see Errol I
got a dell down here as gonna see miss
cheap
no not adel they'll be honest
[Music]
this is an average American family and
so is this and so are these every family
is different but some families are more
different than others
[Music]
[Music]
it's hideous it's horrible it's home is
that really a status you can make it
hello Wednesday what do you have there
I'm not sure strange there's usually a
motorist clown attached to the other end
of these
[Music]
come now Gomez don't forget to kick your
father good night
Yes Mother blow f6 fire in the hole
[Music]
yes you sunk my battleship well done
Pugsley I wish something would liven up
this already tedious day
thanks for trying Ichabod
I'm just not that good with people
there is one thing I'm good at
mission was to find out what they knew
but that's kind of difficult now that
you killed everyone I just don't think
you're cut out for intelligence this is
your last shot oh my god you have jelly
all over your face
I'm definitely posting that on insta is
it too late to home-school me are you
CIA streaming if Kim finds out we got me
by nine-year-old my career is over
what's the option kill her make it look
like an accident
maybe the stairs what Wow still
recording we can cut a deal I'm sure
that she came here to be a spy it's just
to be clear this is a one-time
arrangement never again shooting range
Ops force try to walk away from the
explosion
well I detected tests I could smell a
lie endorphins release Noda and the
ultimate tell slightest blink of an eye
like this JJ I admire all of your
tattoos JJ I believe he is that you've
never taken steroids damn she's good
when you look out there what do you see
90 civilians minimal security software
meter smiling people having fun we
should try it sometime
Marty
the objective of this exercise was to
get past me a good idea might be to
cause the distraction because otherwise
there'd be zero chance of you
[Music]
what is he doing looks like the wedding
at the end of Shrek do you remember the
night we met ladies and gentlemen of the
jury you have been witness to the
unspeakable horrors of the defendants
heinous crimes you've seen ghastly
injuries smashed in faces broken jaws
[Music]
the defendant please rise
four years I've carried as a guilt but
I'm to blame for everything if we hadn't
trusted you promise you'll never leave
business it's about another messy girl
isn't it did and you dimwit no we've
very disturbed sick individual you'll be
the first nationally televised drama in
history he look nice partner I'm
disguised as an attorney today I ain't
get very scared but you know he's also
really dreamy
earthlings you don't know that will
shock you we are your worst nightmares
it's all I it is a capital murder case
and you are skating on thin ice this is
about catching a monster
[Music]
the killings were extremely wicked
shockingly evil vile did you do these
things Ted this is all gonna end it's
only gonna happen to tarnish it traveled
light years through space to find
intelligent life
[Music]
Shawn's back but there's a new arrival
in town who's a little alien meet Luva
[Music]
[Music]
she's a little mischievious she's a
little curious
[Music]
but above all she's a little lost
to get her backhaul we'll take one small
step for land one giant leap for mankind
[Applause]
Farmageddon are Shaun the Sheep movie
[Music]
listen to me something is wrong
something is wrong with me Lizzy I know
that's why we need to get you help I'm
dying what's happening oh my god what's
happening
what is it I don't know
[Music]
you know what you have to do
[Music]
well you know what happens now
[Music]
guys like this only have three options
value life in prison or we start talking
laughs kick what how long my kiss to be
around this
she look at that yeah we don't tolerate
stupidity got that yeah one the Europe
rats on them why you got one you're
right that was your first of all Fred
gave to me need to be a ioin I think row
family don't make yo [ __ ] man now listen
talk to me Babs you know what about you
they go like it you're better than these
races I don't know what to do
in this business you've got to stay
focused or follow right down the rabbit
hole what if I take all this stuff off
and I'm still a piece of [ __ ] you have
involved right I'll answer your phone
don't show up in meetings anymore I
don't even know if you remember I don't
know what they're gonna do you need to
get the kids I got you it's set for you
to come back home now you have no choice
you're still breathing because I am
never inches pink on me
is it true desi said that you're an evil
man I wanna sing a little ditty for my
sweet very short friend Rebecca who is
turning 22 tomorrow when quit I won't
give you something anyway never had
before
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's an amazing day in wine country when
was the last time we were all together I
just want this to feel like a regular
vacation and somewhere in there I'll
just slide into 50 age is just a number
what would you say your souls age is 18
old enough to drink and bone don't have
my own car yet but I have a bike
I made itineraries so everything we're
gonna do a minute-by-minute on the trip
we have lavender popping corn that's not
enough Molly oh I did Molly in college
but she went back to her boyfriend slow
brain when the girls weekend huh just
remember guys whatever gets said is
probably what the person has always felt
and the alcohol just let it out
this weekend is a mess can't even plan a
fun birthday trip if you were just to
let go everything will just fall into
place will Feliz do you think throwing
the itineraries out the window was on
the itinerary guess I'll never know
if we can't get through weekend together
and I'm completely lost
[Music]
that's what she said these women I have
known for 20-plus years and yeah
sometimes I want to tell this one to
[ __ ] off you're gonna [ __ ] us that's
what intimacy looks like
this one's good what's it called again
white wine freakin love it
[Music]